>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> Elizabeth Peterson:
Hi everyone.
I am Betsy Peterson the director
of the American Folk
Life Center.
And, on behalf of the
staff and everyone here
at the library I want
to welcome you all today
to the latest presentation
in the Benjamin Botkin
Lecture Series.
The series is an opportunity
for the American Folklife Center
to present the very best
scholarship in folklore,
ethnomusicology, oral history,
and cultural heritage studies.
And, today is no different.
Each lecture is also video
taped, I should say right now,
and I'm trying not to
rustle my papers, but,
we'll see how that goes.
At any rate, everything is
video taped and will become part
of the lectures at the
American Folklife Center.
So, with that said, if you do
have a phone turned on right now
or any other electronic
device, please, there you go,
please turn it off now.
Today's lecture is
a two for, we are,
we have two distinguished
guests with us today.
We're going to speaking
about their recent
completed publication,
the award winning
Picturing America,
Portraits of National
Heritage, no,
Portraits of National Endowment
for the Arts Folk Masters.
But first, let me
tell you a little bit
about the two gentlemen who
are the authors of this book.
Tom Pich is a native New Yorker
and a professional photographer.
And, over the past 25 years,
in addition to his
commercial photography work,
he has traveled across the
United States photographing
hundreds of National
Heritage Fellows
for the National
Endowment for the Arts
and documenting traditional
artists also
for the Smithsonian
Center for Folklife in
And Cultural Heritage.
His portraiture of National
Heritage Fellows is featured
on the NEA website and has been
exhibited at the Lincoln Center
on the Performing Arts in New
York and the Kennedy Center
for the Performing Arts here
in Washington DC as well
as the National Museum
of the American Indian
and in the Russel
Senate Office Building.
As you know, the National
Heritage Fellowship Award is the
highest honor, in the United
States, that can be bestowed
on traditional artists.
So, when Tom started thinking
about publishing his work,
it was a natural choice to turn
to Barry Bergey, a well known
and respected folklorist.
Barry Bergey is also the
former Director of the Folk
and Traditional Arts Program
at the National Endowment
for the Arts.
And, during his 29
year tenure at NEA,
he oversaw grant
making programs.
Helped shape cultural
policy served as manager
of the National Heritage
Fellowship Programs
and provided counsel to the
U.S. Department of State
on international
cultural policy issues.
Prior to joining the
NEA, Barry serves
as the State Folk Arts
Coordinator for his home state
of Missouri where he
first gained renown
for documenting traditional
musicians in Missouri
and in the Arkansas Ozarks.
In the course of his
distinguished career,
Barry has served as a field
working, festival organizer,
radio producer, curator,
and arts administrator
and chief bottle washer and
a little bit of everything.
Among other accomplishments,
in 2005, Barry was a member
of the U.S. Delegation
to UNESCO involved
in drafting the Composed
Convention on the Diversity
of Cultural Expressions.
And, in 2014, he served as
one of three U.S. delegates
at the Biannual Organization
of American States,
not good to throw
these acronyms around,
at the Biannual Organization
of American States Meeting
of Member Cultural
Ministers in Haiti.
Today, they're going
to talk about the book.
And also, after our lecture
and discussion today,
they will be doing a book
signing in the foyer.
So please, if you haven't picked
up a copy already, please do.
And, I'm sure, they would
love to talk with all of you.
So, I will just turn it over
to Barry and Tom and tank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Barry Bergey: Thanks Betsy.
I'm suddenly feeling tired
after hearing all that.
I don't know what happened.
But, we're happy
to be here today.
Thanks so much for coming out.
You know, this project started
out as an idea for an exhibit.
And, I thought that'd be easy
because Tom's already
taken the photographs.
And then, somewhere along
the line it became a book
which meant I had
to do some writing
which was a little more
work than I expected.
But, I thought, at first,
I should tell you
just a little bit
about the National
Heritage Fellowships.
As Betsy said, it's the highest
form of recognition of folk
and traditional artists
in the United States.
It was started in 1982
by Bess Lomax Hawes
who was then the director
of folk arts at the NEA.
And, it was meant to honor our
significant living treasures.
It was really based on a
Japanese program and concept
of honoring what they call
national living treasures.
And so, she patterned
it after that.
And, through the years,
more than 430 artists have now
been recognized with this award.
And, Tom's photographed
220 some at this point.
So, the book became the process
of trying to select out of
that group 100 artists
to feature.
But, I think, Bess
really best summed it
up in describing what the
Heritage Fellowships are.
And, this is the only
reading we're going to do.
It's not a book reading, but,
I wanted to read you this quote
from Bess because I
think it said a lot
about what was intended for
the Heritage Fellowships.
She said this; of all
the activities assisted
by the Folk arts program,
these fellowships are among the
most appreciated and applauded,
perhaps, because they present to
Americans a vision of themselves
and other country, a
vision somewhat idealized
but profoundly longed
for, and so,
in significant ways
profoundly true.
It is a vision of a confident
and openhearted nation whee
differences can be seen
as exciting instead
of fear laden.
Where people of good will,
across all manner of racial,
linguistic, and historical
barriers, can find common ground
in understanding
solid craftsmanship,
virtuoso techniques, and
deeply felt expressions.
And, I don't think it could
be said better than that.
So, when we thought about
choosing a photograph
for the cover of the
book, at the time,
we wanted to pick
a good photograph.
And now that I look back on
it, I think we selected one
that conveys a second message
which is, in this case,
Julia Parker is standing
I a meadow
in Yosemite National Park.
So, there is a living national
treasure standing in the midst
of a world heritage site.
And really, those two concepts
of heritage have
blend nicely together.
Tom do you want to
say a little bit
about this photograph
before we go on?
We'll get back to, sort of,
where all this started, but,
maybe you'd like to
describe a little bit
about how this photograph
came about.
>> Tom Pich: Right, I, over
the past couple of months,
I've had a lot of questions
about did I take the photos
of the deer in my studio
or superimpose them?
Are those cut out cardboard deer
that I travel with all the time?
So, you know, but this time
they didn't keep my luggage.
But, I came into the park that
morning to visit with Julia.
And, she was teaching
at the museum there.
And, the weather was awful
and it was to get worse
and they were evacuating
the park.
So, nobody was allowed in,
fortunately they did let me come
in and visit with her.
And, as people were leaving,
I had the opportunity to walk
through the forest with Julia.
And, that morning, in a break
in the rain, she told me all
about her spirit and she
would touch the trees
and she would tell me about
how she was part of this tree
and part of the sky and
the earth and the water
that was cascading
over the falls.
Later that afternoon, as
the weather was starting
to get worse, if you look
closely, there's snow,
there's hail, there's
a lot of rain.
I asked Julia, which I always do
to all artists, where would you
like to be photographed,
not where I want to?
And, she said her
favorite meadow.
So, we drove to this location.
And, the road was
a river of water.
And, Julia's about 5 foot 1.
And so, I went across into the
grass and I set up the tripod
and I went and got the
camera, set that up,
then I covered the
camera from the rain,
and then I brought Julia over.
And, it wasn't until after
I looked at the photograph
and realized, when I walked
into the meadow I
followed this natural path
that I didn't even
recognize at the time.
So, Julia stood there and
I was about five feet,
you know, away from her.
And, as we started talking
and I started photographing,
the deer just rose
up out of the grass
and they just stood
there for the photo.
And, once that happened, as
I do in most of my photos,
I might have photographed
for a minute, I knew I had it
and then we're finished.
I don't move all
over the meadow.
I just, it's an instinct that
I had from the beginning so.
And then, I realized that
everything she told me about
and talked to me
about, probably,
that morning was right
there in front of me.
And they all, to me, came out
to honor her, the weather,
the magnificence of the
view, the animals, the earth.
So, I'm forever grateful
for having been there
that moment that she gave me.
As I understand also,
that meadow is
where she collects her materials
to make her basic right.
So, she has, she has the
makings of a basket in her hands
and there's a roll of like
orange brush back there
that she uses to make
these baskets, plus,
she goes to this meadow to
get a lot of her medicines
that she uses for healing.
So, this is her favorite
place, her favorite meadow,
her special place where she
comes to just spend time
and think and collect
what she needs, so.
And, I spoke to her
just three weeks ago.
And, she's doing well and I'm
on my way to visit her again
to do some more recording.
So, I'm grateful
to that as well.
But, what I'll do is go
on and talk a little bit
of how this all came
about, this works.
So, this National Geographic
article changed my whole life.
I was sitting in my apartment
in New York in the winter
and I read, I, my National
Geographic came in the mail
and I opened it up, I looked at
the cover that was intriguing
and I went, and I
came upon this article
about National Heritage Fellows.
And, I knew immediately,
immediately that's
what I wanted to do.
Didn't matter what I was doing
to what level I was
doing my photography,
this is what I wanted to do.
So, I got on the telephone,
there were no cell phones then,
and I dial the operator
and I asked her
to call National Geographic.
And, she put me through.
And, I did get through to one
of the writers of this article.
And, he said, well, we
really didn't have much to do
with it besides the photography
but you have to contact the NEA.
So, I said okay.
So, I hung up with Boras
and I call the operator back
and says can you please
put me through to the NEA?
And, they said sure.
And, next thing I know,
hello how can I help you?
I said is this NEA?
She goes yes this is
NRA, how can I help you?
I was like no I want the NEA.
So, after a couple of more calls
to the operator, thank God,
I didn't get them
ones every time
because they probably
would've hung up on me.
I got the number for the NEA.
I still don't know what I was
doing, maybe I still don't.
And, I, a lovely woman, Rose
Morgan, picked up the phone.
And, I can tell you,
I still don't know
to this day what I
ever said to her.
But, she said, well, if you're
ever in Washington stop by
and I'll introduce you to
our director at the time.
And I said, oh that's great.
Let's fast forward
about four hours.
My wife comes up from work a and
she sees me packing my suitcase.
And she goes where you going?
I said to Washington.
She goes, oh what for?
I says, I have no idea.
The next morning I got on the
train, went to Washington,
found the right oak door in
the old post office building,
Rose Morgan answered the door,
walked me in, introduced me
to Dan Chehe, I told him my
crazy ideas, and he said well,
we'll help you as
much as we can.
And, here it is all these years
later and I'm still on the road.
So this, and, we talked
about it, and Marjorie Hunt
who was the co-writer
in this article,
how the words really
inspired me at the time.
And, I realize that more now,
as we're losing magazines
and that the written word
really will inspire journalist
in young people as
we go forward.
So, that was my first
day in Washington.
I don't even know if I stayed
that night or what I was doing.
But, you know, it wasn't long
after I went on the road.
And, well, the Heritage
Fellowships have a very strong
connection to the library.
So, I wanted to mention
that, that the ceremony,
there are three elements of the
Heritage programs, generally,
I think of them as the personal,
the political, and the public.
And, the personal
one, of course,
is to honor the artists
and their families.
So, we have a banquet
here in the great hall
of the library each year
honoring the Heritage Fellows.
The political one is
the ceremony itself
which is held right next door
here in Coolidge Auditorium now.
And often, of course,
congress people are invited
to come to that.
And then, there's the
public event associated
with the Heritage Fellowship
which is a concert
that's been done recently
at the Lisner Auditorium
on the George Washington
University Campus
where artists are able
to present their work
whether it be music or craft
or storytelling or
dance, whatever it may be.
So, those three elements
are connected.
But, all of that of
course is documented.
Tom comes down most of the time
to document those
events as well.
And, the archive for the
heritage fellowship is located
here in the American Folklife
Center at the library.
So, we've had a strong
and ongoing connection
to the library for
years and years.
And, we hope that continues.
But, it is a way for
the materials related
to the heritage fellowships
to live on.
Now, maybe you want to go back
to the beginning
where you started.
>> Tom Pich: So, we've
been jumping back
and forth a little bit.
But, it is a great honor
to cover these events here.
The building's just
so spectacular.
So, this is the first
photograph.
So I get, I received,
before I left,
a list of the Heritage
fellows up until that time.
And so, Sandman Simms lived
in New York and so did I.
So, once again not really having
any idea what I was doing,
I approached, I called him and
he walked me over to his house.
And, I had this like,
sort of really,
the vision in my head was to
shoot it with medium format
and black and white,
it should be beautiful.
And, I visited with him,
and this was shot
with a [inaudible].
And, I do have some color
but mostly black and white.
And, even before I get
back, once I seen the film,
I realized the format's
wrong and it all has
to be photographed in
color because there's just
such colorful people in
spirit and what they do.
So, this is the first photograph
that I had ever taken
of the Fellows.
And so, we went on
and you'll see
in the next one where
I follow that.
This is the second
photograph I've ever taken,
and it was on my first journey.
So, I left New York, we crossed
over the George Washington
Bridge into New Jersey.
And so, I was following
this line.
If you lived, the
closest person to me,
then we just went all the way
down to the Appalachians, so,
it was quite a journey.
We were welcomed, we
had a wonderful visit.
And, once again,
it was the shop.
And I was still, had a lot
of vision of how I was taught
from school and other mentors
that, when I was photographing,
the window, the light
was just too much.
So, I noticed that, when
we came up the driveway,
he had a flag hanging off
either this house or his home.
And, we went and
took the flag off.
And, my friend Micheal
is standing outside
that window holding the flag.
And, that's what
I love about it.
So, it's, kept your
eye on this subject not
to go out the window.
That's something that
we learned in school.
And, we went on and this was
all the way down in Charleston.
Interesting story, once we
got into this neighborhood,
we were asked what
we were doing there.
And, when I went up and
asked for Mr. Simmons,
this young man said
hold on a second.
And, for ten minutes
I stood at the doorway
and nobody ever came back.
I'm knocking on the door.
So, I walked out to the street
and I watched this young man run
across an intersection.
And, I was saying
to Micheal, look,
that's the person
I just spoke to.
And, a few minutes
later, it was him
and another young boy
that ran that way.
And, I'm like, you could
see them moving around.
And, next thing you know, they
ended up, they were sending
out a change to the
oldest brother
that there was somebody there
to meet their grandfather.
And it was the oldest brother
to allow us to come in.
And, we met Mr. Simmons
and he took us into a shed
that was right next to the house
where he does a lot of work
and he was kind enough
to start up the fire.
And, I don't know from
this point of view, but,
I remember asking him
specifically, that fire was
so hot that I could see
the glow in his hand.
And I said, isn't that
hot, is that burning you?
And he says no you
get used to it.
And then, on his skin looks like
cigarette burns or something.
I said but they're the embers
of the fire that would come
and rest on his skin
over the years.
And, the great thing, I think
it was over ten years later
that we were reunited
back up here together
and to be photographed with
Phil Simmons was a great honor.
So, this was a journey
all the way
from New York and starting down.
And we were being educated
at the same time being
lost in different places.
But, we picked up speed and
we started to get an idea.
And, once again, I looked
at the number the other day
of Mr. Simmons, I took
no more than 40 photos.
And, we weren't even
seeing them,
they were photographed
and filmed.
>> Barry Bergey: You
were going to film.
>> Tom Pich: Yeah, yeah.
>> Barry Bergey: Catacomb.
>> Tom Pich: Yeah.
And, I counted the
number of slides
in his folder there were
only 40 and I gasped now
like oh my God we only have 40
and we only need 1 good one.
And the same thing when
we went to meet Mary Jane.
Her folder is like this thin,
she has 2 sheets of slides, so,
there's 20 in each one,
and I don't think the
second one's even full.
And, I went to meet with her.
I remember, walking up
the stairs to her home,
very warm day, but
just so welcoming,
every one of these people
just so welcoming to me.
And, we sat there and
talked and she was one
of the most beautiful
women I have ever seen
and had the opportunity
to photograph.
And I just asked her to
look off over to the street.
And, by that time, there were
a bunch of children gathering.
And, while we were doing
it, the ice cream man came,
and you know the
sound of those bells
and all the kids were excited.
So, I asked Micheal I said
let's buy everybody ice cream.
And so, everybody had
ice cream that day
and it was a wonderful day,
once again, maybe 30 photos
and that's what we
walked away with.
And, I'm forever grateful to
have that opportunity too.
So, this journey is just
taking us, you know,
through the south
from the coast.
And, we'll go inland all
the way to Ray Hicks' home.
And, this is Banner
Elk North Carolina.
And so, you see we
primarily chose this
to show what happened
on my first journey.
And, I think it was
really, if any group
of photographs ever
said anything about me,
these were the rawest
photographs that,
I didn't read much about the
person I was going to see, so,
I didn't have any
preconceived ideas.
And, what I wanted to do,
I just let the landscape
and the person really
make the photograph.
And so, this is some of
the most powerful as Barry
and I would go back and
forth trying to select photos
and why should they, why there
are very so wonderful ones.
>> Barry Bergey:
It was interesting.
When we started looking at
the 220 or so to try to figure
out what to put in the book,
we realized that first
journey we selected almost
every photograph.
Something about that spontaneity
and the exposure to
it, I don't know.
But it was interesting
that almost every one
of those photographs.
And, we tried to
select photographs
because they had
good visual impact.
But, also there was a story
behind the photograph often
as well.
So, those two factors
played into the selecting.
>> Tom Pich: Right,
so here's a couple
of New York kids trying
to find Ray Hicks.
Well, Michael had the
great idea well let's go
to the post office, they'll
know where Ray Hicks lives.
And the guy was wonderful
he said you're almost there.
Go down the road a few
miles, when you get to the Y
in the road, you just go down
to the left, go into the valley,
and you'll say Ray Hicks' home.
And, we followed that, and we
were excited, we're following,
we get to the Y, you go down
you can see a cluster of houses,
and we pull up to a
mailbox that says Hicks.
And, we're like,
oh, it's right here.
But, the problem was, the
next mailbox said Hicks also
and so did about
five other ones.
And so, I got out, and there
was this dog barking behind
a screen.
And, I'm walking up to the house
and I'm a little apprehensive.
And, from behind the dog
and the screen was a voice.
What do you want?
And we were asking
for Ray Hicks.
And this person, even though
her mailbox said Hicks,
said he was down the road.
And, we did eventually get to
his home and he welcomed us
and we spent most of the
day with him and his wife
and he walked me around to show
me his garden and, you know,
where he collects
water and crayfish.
And, he was excited about he
had just gotten electricity
in the house.
So, he had a wire coming into
the living room with a wire
and a pigtail and a
little light bulb.
And, that was the extent
of their modern day
conveniences for the most part.
So, but, and then, there's a
whole bunch of travel stories
that surround after this.
But, we didn't document those.
I think I was too scared.
And then, on to John Jackson.
And if, this is one
of the photographs
that I spent an afternoon
with John.
And, we were doing it in his,
taking some photos
in his living room.
And, I talked with him
more, probably, for an hour
and a half before we
even I bring in a camera
so they feel comfortable.
So, I started taking pictures of
John and it just wasn't working.
So, we agreed that I would
come back the next day.
And, the cameras were packed
up and put in the car.
And, I was walking out
the front of the house
and John was walking and
he was at the door, and,
I just noticed the light on him.
And, I said John, hold on.
I got the camera, I took
half a dozen exposures
and I knew I had his picture.
And, I never went
back, we didn't,
I said I think we're good.
And, next time I would see
him a festival or so on.
But, somebody asked me
once, oh you've got pictures
of such and such an artist.
And, do you have a picture of
them doing this or do you have?
And I says no I usually, I
look for one photo that will,
you know, say who they
might be, who they are.
>> Barry Bergey: One of
the interesting things
about John is his house is
filled with Civil War artifacts.
You know, he used to
take a medal detector
out across the battlefields and
find beneath the earth bullets
and remnants of swords
and all sorts of things.
And John, professionally,
was a caretaker, handyman,
but also a grave digger.
And, I've always thought
it was kind of ironic
that he spent his
professional life putting bodies
under the ground and his side
light was looking underneath the
earth for other treasures.
It just seemed like
an interesting irony,
in addition to being a great,
great singer and musician.
But, I always thought that was
sort of an interesting dynamic,
one of the most wonderful
people you could ever meet.
I think it comes through
in this photograph.
>> Tom Pich: I think
we spent, probably,
the first hour talking
about, because you'd walk
into the house and everywhere
were boxes or tin cans,
Maxwell House Coffee cans.
I was like John what are these?
He goes, oh those are just,
you know, old bullets or.
And I have them, today I have a
couple of gifts that he gave me.
It looked like just a pancake.
So I said, what was this, he
goes that looks like a bullet
that hit someone
that flatten out.
Yeah, and he did, he had
belt buckles, broken swords.
And he ws generous with
all of it, you know.
And so I thanked him and I still
have those and display those.
Well, here is my longest
second trip in beginning.
This is 1993.
And, there I am in jeans and
an jean jacket in Louisiana
in Saint Bernard Parish
photographing Ervin Perez,
one of the Fellows, and then
below with Canray Fontenot
and my friend Micheal
Singh who's
in the back now taking
these photos of me.
My girls get a good laugh
out of what I looked like
and what I wore back then.
I just told Barry this
story last evening.
On Monday I was in New York and
presenting to, I was talking
to some people that
had bought the book.
And, they have a
receptionist that has been part
of this whole thing, seeing me
coming in and out and talking.
And I said did you never, did
we never show you the book?
And she said no.
And, I went to this page
and I showed her that.
And, she goes oh, bluejeans
and a bluejean jacket?
I says yeah, 1993.
She goes, oh I wasn't
even born yet.
So, I felt real good about that.
But, these are some of the
other journeys and I'm grateful
to have these photographs
of realizing how crazy a
haircut I had at that time.
But, once again, we
will welcome so much.
We had dinners with both these
gentlemen and their families
after we photographed them.
I don't think these, Canray,
the gentleman on the bottom,
he had just gotten
back after being
in the hospital for a few weeks.
We went outside, we photographed
for maybe ten minutes
at the most.
Then he asked me to go dig out
some crayfish from the front
of the yard so we
could have dinner.
And, we did, so we
learned how to do that.
And, once again, he was the
ending part of this journey.
And we were in Eunice
with Boisec.
And, we were out on his porch.
And, a storm was coming in.
And the midst the rain, the
midst of the rain started coming
through the screen and it
made him uncomfortable.
And, the light was
terrible, the lighting was.
And, we went to his
living room once again.
I asked him if I come
back the next day,
if the weather was
better and he agreed.
Put the cameras in the car, the
car was underneath the carport,
tin, just a piece
of corrugated tin.
And, as I was about
to get in the car,
the wind was whipping
up, and I noticed
that the rain was picking up
and all the animals started
scurrying for shelter.
And I asked him if
he would come out.
There was a rocking chair
that was being moved
with the weather.
And he agreed even though
he said he didn't want
to catch a cold.
He put on his jacket, put
on his hat, he sat there.
And as I started taking
the picture, this rooster,
or chicken, it's a rooster,
started walking through
the frame.
And, I have six frames of this
photograph rooster walking
through, walking out.
Soon as he walked out,
I knew I had the picture
and I told him thank you very
much and we were finished.
And so.
>> Barry Bergey: Kind of
an interesting element
of that photograph, behind the,
the story behind
the photograph is
that Boisec name is
dry wood in french.
And, he got that nickname
because, as a young man
when he worked in the fields,
when it started to rain,
they always said he was
the first one to run
into the barn to stay dry.
And now, it turns out that Tom's
photograph was another attempt
to photograph him and
avoid the rain so.
>> Tom Pich: He did, he was
very uncomfortable feeling
that mist coming in, and
then to get him to agree
to step outside for this photo.
And, it didn't take, out of
probably 20 seconds it was over.
So, and we were glad that
the rooster decided to show.
>> Barry Bargey: The rooster has
other functions in Cajun culture
as well, regarding Mardi
Gras and usually a plate
on the table generally.
[ Background noise ]
>> Tom Pich: As I went through
the 90s and started evolving
into being a better
documentarian, to gathering
as much information as I
could, I sat with Flory Jagoda.
And, I would ask a question,
especially even more now,
I'll ask a question and
I'll just let them talk.
I might not speak
for 15, 20 minutes.
I just, as, and, if I have
to like redirect more,
encourage them, it might be as
few word sentences as a can.
She wanted to, we, her
house is just all these
wonderful instruments.
But, she went on to tell
me a story about her
as a young girl and
an accordion.
And that was one of the
most incredible stories I've
ever heard.
And, I'll let Barry
finish up with that.
>> Barry Bergey:
Well that story was,
her family was living in Bosnia.
And, she was about 17
years old at the time.
And, her father could tell
that the Holocaust
was on the horizon.
And so, he had got her
a passport, somehow,
a forged passport,
and he put her
on the train with her accordion.
And, he said just keep
playing the accordion
and if the officials come up,
just keep playing the accordion
and they may not
check your identity.
And, she was able to
escape Bosnia and 42
of her family members
were killed in the,
including her grandmother,
who is the person she
learned her songs from.
So, she wanted to carry on, of
course, that family tradition.
And, the accordion you see on
the right side of the screen,
the little white according is
the accordion that she carried
with her on that train ride.
And, just recently, the Virginia
Foundation for the Humanities,
the Folk Arts Program there, had
someone restore the accordion
so she could play it again.
But, it's quite a
story both tragic
and has its happy
ending as well for her.
>> Tom Pich: So, when she
was telling me this story,
I asked her what
happened to the accordion,
she said she still had it.
And, I asked can we get it
and put it in the photograph.
And, the full photograph
shows the whole instrument.
But, I mean that's
to me so special.
And each one of these visits,
yeah, I could go over, you know,
sitting with Ray Hicks and I
can still feel the temperature
of the day and sitting with
Flory and just feel how,
you know, she's just a
beautiful woman in spirit
and telling this story and
at the same time being able
to smile for the photograph.
And, she's proud that,
you know, that she had it
and that there was the interest
in for it to be restored.
When I heard that, that
was incredible too.
So I, so everything
starts to evolve.
And then, some of them
take on different stories.
And, we show you this one
because Wade Maynard turned 100.
Correct?
>> Barry Bergey: Right.
>> Tom Pich: So, Barry and I
that day, that day met and,
in Michigan and drove
up to their house to,
Barry was presenting
him with a plaque or.
>> Barry Bergey: We were giving
him a letter from the Chairman
of the National Endowment for
the Arts to congratulate him
on his 100th birthday.
So, this was the only trip
I had been able to take
with Tom and his journeys.
>> Tom Pich: There was a
couple other funny stories.
But, within that,
we got to the house
and Wade's wife plays for him.
So, I thought it was appropriate
to photograph the
two of them together.
And then, off we went
with this whole family.
The house was full of
children and grandchildren
and great grandchildren.
And, off we went to the
local high school where,
as you can see in the smaller
photograph, was full wall
to wall with townspeople that
came out to hear them play
and to honor him
for his birthday.
Well, the ceremony
went on proceeding.
And, I was off the side of the
stage taking some photographs.
And, Wade came, after a song he
was trying to wave me to come
on stage and I kept saying no.
So finally, he said to the
audience, I'm not going
to play unless Tom comes out.
So, I came out, I stood next
to him, he introduced me,
I said a couple of
things and all the sudden,
someone in the audience just
stood up and said sit down.
And, I was stunned.
And, I looked at Barry in
the audience and my eyes were
like this big, I froze.
And somebody else shouted from
the audience and I'm like, wait,
I got to get, I got to go,
I got to get off the stage.
They want to hear you
and they're telling
me to go sit down.
And, I mean, so I left.
And I was, it had me.
And, I left the building.
And Barry had seen me leave and
he met me out in the courtyard.
And, I was like I didn't mean
to come out and I'm trying
to explain myself that
Wade wanted me out there
and I didn't mean to upset the
audience and stop the music.
And, we went over to a cousin
or of Wades and we talked to him
about it, you know, we
didn't mean to upset them
and why the reaction in
the audience was so great.
And he says, they weren't doing
that, they were asking for Wade
to play the song Sit Down.
>> Barry Bergey: There's a
great gospel song that Wade
and Julia were well known
for where she says sit down
and he says I can't sit down.
She says sit down, he
says I can't sit down,
she says sit down, I can't
sit down I just got to heaven
and I got to walk around.
So, that's what they
were calling for.
>> Tom Pich: And I tell you
I would've been happy being
in heaven at that moment.
I don't know what, I
was, that was a tough,
that was a tough moment.
But I was relieved afterwards.
So, the visits take on all
kinds of different directions
and the stories become
more interesting
than the photos sometimes.
And a similar thing
happened with Chunky Sanchez.
I know he wasn't
in great health.
But, a week after he received
his Heritage fellowship in 2013,
I flew out to San Diego to
visit with him, now I set it
up with his family,
with his wife.
And, I'm always at a location.
So, we, I asked Chunky
where would you
like to be photographed,
before I got out there?
And, he said Chicano Park.
Now, if anybody's
been in San Diego,
there's wonderful
murals in this park.
So, I arrived there about an
hour plus before I was supposed
to meet Chunky.
And, I was watching these,
all these cars pull up
and families would get out.
And then, they started putting
on these costumes
and headdresses.
So, of course I'm
interested, and I walk over
and says is there
a parade today.
And they said no we're
here to meet a friend.
And, questions on questions,
and they said we're here
to honor Chunky Sanchez.
And I said how did you know
he was going to be here?
Oh, his wife called us.
And, he's such an advocate
for the different communities,
for Mexico and the Aztec
communities, that they came
to be, just to witness
me photographing him.
And, that's when I realized,
I couldn't just photograph
Chunky alone.
I put them all in the photo.
And, it just was incredible
how many people loved this man
for them to show up.
And, it's a much
better photograph
than me just photographing
him alone.
He's since passed away.
But, I think his,
he's on a mural there
in the park now too
honoring him.
>> Barry Bargey: Right
and they named the school
after him as well.
We had a big dinner at a table
of about 40 people at a school
that they named after
him as well.
But, how exciting that that many
people would take time to come
out and dress up and
just in his honor, so.
They take on all
different forms.
So, this brings us back
here in the mid 200s.
I had to start to think
about what I was doing,
if I was gathering, if
I was doing my trips
or these heritage
fellows justice.
And, it all came one night
after listening to Joe Wilson.
And, Joe Wilson was
a dear friend.
And, he was giving
a talk one day here.
>> Tom Pich: At the
library right.
He was being honored
as a living legend.
Then there was as symposium
that occurred during
that period time as well.
And so, what Joe was talking
about is how he dedicated
himself, and if he had,
whatever he had to bring with
him to record the artists
that he was visiting he
would make those efforts.
And, I'd sort of just
given up on video instead
of taking all this
equipment just focus
on taking the photograph.
And, at that point it was, I was
bringing lightening equipment
and all kinds of crazy stuff.
And that night, I realized
I had to rededicate myself,
if I was going to do
this, to spend time,
don't spend just a day, if I
needed two days or three days
with a Fellow to record their
words to record their visions.
And so I did.
And, this next slide,
and it's a silent piece,
but it shows you how I took
Joe's words and put them
into the work I do now.
If you watch Joe, and
if anybody knows Joe,
if you ask him a question, he
could go on for about 12 hours.
This is a video I did time laps.
>> Barry Bergey: Sitting
on his porch that's the
New River behind him there.
>> Tom Pich: At this
point, I wasn't even there.
I was in the kitchen
cooking with his wife.
I didn't even go out to
reset the camera exposure.
So, we started out in the
like, he never left that chair
and he continued his story.
Poor Barry had to
listen to those.
>> Barry Bergey: There's
some great stories in there.
The one I remember, at least,
is as Joe talked about the mix
of cultures in southwestern
Virginia
and northeastern Tennessee,
because, in that area,
those remoter areas, there's
a mix of Anglo American,
Native American, and
African American folks
who moved into that region.
He said yeah folks moved
here he said and they,
somehow they took a high
dive into the gene pool.
But he had a great way
of expressing himself.
>> Tom Pich: Yeah, I remember
some of the things he was trying
to tell me when I told
Barry it'd be interesting
to listen to it.
So that, and since that moment,
I have really rededicated,
when I go visit with a
Fellow, we have a day schedule.
But, if something's
changing, I'm very flexible
with my schedule to stay
long or come back, revisit,
to make sure, more than
anything, if I'm trying
to capture some video and
I don't bring in a lot
of video equipment, we
try to make it really easy
that the equipment is
not more than who we are
and that I'll spend as much time
and I'm gathering a
lot more information
and having a really
good time at it.
There's a few photos left.
But this, this is
a trip of destiny.
And, this happened a
summer ago that I had,
I was supposed to
go to the Dakotas.
And then, by some false
wiring and fate I asked one
of the Heritage Fellows
from Maryland where he'd
like to be photographed.
He said Seattle.
I said how do we
go all the way to?
And, I said okay.
So, I thought, well if
I'm going to Seattle,
I'm going to visit
a lot of people.
So, I spent time in Seattle and
all the way up through Alaska
from Ketchikan to
Sitka to Juneau.
And, when things are in the
stars and everything aligned,
it works out and I'm grateful
because this young lady,
who happens to be in the
book a couple of times,
is a deer friend and
has passed on since.
And, when I visited with her,
she had terminal bone cancer.
But, her spirit was so alive.
And, she's known for this,
when she makes her capes,
when she twirls how they look.
So, she took me to a spot where
she wanted to be photographed.
And, in that area were
fresh bear tracks.
So, that unnerved
me a little bit.
And, at this time,
she was on crutches.
So, her husband Denny
and myself were there.
And, I'm asking him
very naively, like so,
I know you can't outrun a
bear but is that whole thing
about curling up and
covering your neck?
He goes, if they're hungry,
they're going to eat you.
So, I'm like, already saying.
I don't really think
this is the right place.
And, anyway, she says look, and
she sticks out her crutches,
we're bigger than the
bear and we're talking.
So, to fast forward, Denny
says, none of that works.
He goes all you have
to realize you have
to outrun the person
you're with.
And, we both looked at her
and said okay we're good.
And that's where we went
on to take this photograph.
And now, there's a whole
story behind this, you know,
the weaving and the wool like
comes from this particular goat.
She researched back to
her ancestors like 400
or 500 years ago and
found the same bloodline.
And, on one part you could
actually see the DNA strand
that she weaved into it and
that's the DNA strand, but.
>> Barry Bergey: The wool
comes from the mountain goats.
It takes years, sometimes,
to collect it
because they take the
wool off the bushes
as they're shedding the wool.
So, they go out into their,
the woods into the hills
and they will collect the
wool out of the bushes.
>> Tom Pinch: Right, they
won't capture and sheer them.
They do it naturally.
Right after that,
I went up to Juneau
and this is another relationship
to Terry and Clarissa Rizal.
And, I spent, I called
Barry the day after
and said I just spent the
most exhausting 17 hours
with someone in my whole life.
I needed two days to recover.
She was so energetic.
But, she wanted to
show me this place
where she gets her
inspiration from.
And, it's called Eagle Beach.
And there was just a wonderful
moment and you can see
in her work and her
landscape how one is the same.
>> Barry Bergey: In Alaska,
there are several
different types of capes.
This is also made
with the same wool.
The first one you saw is
called Raven's Tail weaving
and this is a Chilkat like it
with the clan lineage
on the back.
>> Tom Pich: But, it was really
amazing, as I was photographing
to realize that the landscape
is what she's wearing.
[ Background noise ]
I'm just going to go back.
So, going to finish
up with this one.
This is the part of the
rededication that I had.
And this just happened
this past year.
This is Elder Roma Wilson and
I had been looking for him
for years and years and years.
And, he comes from Mississippi
and he migrated to Chicago.
Nobody knew where he was.
About 4:00 on a Saturday
morning,
I was researching
Alabama Sunlights
when they were playing
one of his songs.
And, I immediately got
distracted over the Elder,
well, then I found him.
I found a clip on YouTube
that I couldn't believe
was dated correctly.
Within two days, I spoke
to his granddaughter who's
in that picture and I flew
immediately to Detroit
because Elder Roma
Wilson's 106 years old.
And, here is one of the
recordings that we did.
[ Background noise ]
Hello. Yeah I, so, that,
you may hear the sound.
>> You ready.
>> Tom Pich: Yeah I'm ready.
[ Music ]
So, it's just a piece of the.
>> All right, I'm so glad
trouble don't last always.
>> Tom Pich: And, I didn't know
his granddaughter was going
to sing.
And, she was just
handing him the harmonicas
and he was testing them all.
And, he started playing
and this happened.
So, this is a great treat.
And, he went on to play
a few more tunes for me.
He's 106 and he introduced
me to his new wife
because his former wife had
passed away a year earlier,
he goes she's 92.
I says Elder you're
robbing the cradle.
He goes yeah I know.
He had just such a
great since of humor.
I stood up and we finished up
and this is one of the photos
that we did with Elder.
And, we'll be, I'll be going
back visiting with him as well
to do more recordings so.
>> Barry Bergey: So,
the beat goes on.
And you were just up in Chicago
photographing Ella Jenkins
just a.
>> Tom Pich: Short while ago.
>> Barry Bergey: Weeks
ago, she's, what's she 90?
>> Tom Pich: 99, yeah.
>> Barry Bergey: Yeah, 99, okay.
Well, I think that
concludes our presentation.
We'd be happy to take a few
questions if we have time.
I see one back there,
I don't know
if we've got a mike
we're going to use, okay.
Right here, stand up, no,
back there in the white.
>> How yo doing?
My name is Dennis Burrows I'm
from Weehawken New Jersey.
And, I lived in Harlem
for quite a bit.
And, I'm a cinematographer
and a photographer.
And, I do a lot of
documentary stuff.
And, I was wondering, I was
surprised that you told me
that you had somebody back there
holding the flag in the window.
So, I'm wondering
where you draw the line
when you come upon a
scene and you either want
to get just everything as it is
or do you want to add something
or was that just
something that just sort
of happened at the last minute?
>> Tom Pich: Well I, honest,
that was the second
photograph I ever had taken.
It was the first photograph in
the new format with just color.
And, I looked back then
and the instincts of going
to art school, you always
learned keep your eye
in the photo.
If you bring it in this way,
make sure it comes back.
And, my eye kept
going out that window.
And, it's a great
question to ask.
And, that is the only time
that really has occurred.
Now, when we have, we walked
through Michigan with an artist
with different pieces of art.
And yes, we placed
her stuff there.
But, what I love about the
picture and why I show it
and why I say that is because
my two dearest friends,
and one of them being that
gentlemen right there,
we've grown up together and
started this journey together.
It always reminds me of that
they're part of that photo.
And so, that's why, I
don't try to, try to.
>> I'm just asking you because
I was doing a documentary
in New York City
and we were, I was,
you know John Alfred,
he worked DC.
Well, I started the program,
the Professional
Television Training Program
where we had underprivileged
young people
where we taught them how to
do documentary video and film
in the tradition of DC TV which
is basically cinema verite.
And, Discovery Channel came and
got one of my students put them
in a documentary
called the Harlem Diary,
which talks about young people
in Harlem and their lives.
And, I was hired
as a video mentor.
And, I would travel around with
the students just to make sure
that they were being technically
responsible for the video
that they were going
to be taking back.
To add to the piece.
And, one night, we were in
Harlem, like around 130th,
maybe 129th and Frederick
Douglas and they're looking
in the projects because
they're supposed to be meeting
up with a crew that was
going to have a dog fight.
But, that wasn't
going to happen.
And then, the director decided
to create a dog fight and that's
when I got fired because I
said this is not documentary.
So, that's why I asked
a question like that.
>> Tom Pinch: No, I
totally agree with you.
>> And I thought you did
so that's why I asked.
>> Tom Pinch: Yeah and it, yeah
and it's funny because I know,
when I meet with these
Fellows, they'll tell me stories
that other journalists have
come to visit with them.
And they've said, like this
one woman out in Kansas,
it was like 100 degrees,
you know, I'm 77,
he has me in the
cornfield then I'm
in the hay field then
I'm holding this.
I almost passed out
from heat stroke.
And, that person didn't
even, they were just there
to get the image and gather.
And, I approach it
so differently.
I spend a lot of time, before I
even break open the camera bag,
I ask them where they
want to be photographed.
I don't bring any
lights with me anymore.
And, that came on the request of
my oldest daughter saying to me,
she was in Puerto Rico with me
and she said dad you've
just gotten so Hollywood,
I had all these lights.
By the time I sat them
up I've lost the mood.
And, with some of
the elder people,
by the time you put these
lights and the flashes went off,
they were like, I think it
was giving them a stroke.
So, I'm back to just pure
basics, what's there is what.
I.
>> Barry Bergey: Yeah,
and I think, I think that,
we call the book Portraits
because they are portraits.
But, they're really a, what
I see as a collaboration
between Tom and the artists
because they have some agency
in the decision as
well saying well I'd
like to be photographed
here or I'd
like to be photographed there.
So, I think it is a
collaborative piece.
There's a great story
about Woolley McGray who's
in the book Cowboy
Poet from Montana.
And, he didn't want Tom,
originally, to photograph him
because he didn't like
photographers coming
to take his picture because
he had a bad experience.
He was out on his ranch and
somebody came up to document him
and followed him around all
day and they were ordering him
to do this and do that.
And, he was out in the field
throwing some hay bails off the
back of the wagon and the
photographer said could you do
that again for me.
He said you come
back tomorrow at 11am
and I'll be doing
the same thing.
But, he wasn't about
to throw one off
if it didn't need
to be thrown off.
So, you do have that
conversation about things.
>> Tom Pich: So, Barry
sent me to the lions den.
I go all the way to Elko Nevada
and the first morning
I'm there I'm sitting
in a green room waiting
for Woolley McGray to come
and introduce myself and say
I'd love to get your photograph.
It's 0 degrees out but I
want to get a landscape.
And he was, he wouldn't
even talk to me.
He's like why should
you take my picture?
There's nobody else
better in Montana.
And he went on and on and on.
So, he finally agreed
not to beat me up
and to let me photograph him.
He said here's the deal.
You can photograph me.
Don't ask me to look at you and
don't ask me to do anything.
>> Barry Bergey: So,
he definitely stipulated he
wouldn't be photographed riding
a horse as I can recall.
>> Tom Pich: Yeah, oh yeah.
So, I had this, fortunate, just
by fortune, the stage setting
where he was going to speak
looked like an old town.
And, the lighting guys, who I
had met, and we were talking,
and we just put a
spotlight on the set.
And, I put a chair, a
metal chair, I said,
if you just sit there.
And, it was an angle that I
shot it because he's noted
for his red cowboy boots, and
he tucks his jeans inside of it.
And, he never looked at me.
And till this day it's one
of my favorite photographs.
And then, Barry had
heard from Woolley
after and what did he say?
>> Barry Bergey: He termed
that one of his favorites too.
He said something to the
fact that I never need
to be photographed
now I have this one.
>> Tom Pich: So, and he's,
then I stayed with him that day
and he read this wonderful
poetry to the audience except
for this one moment
when he turned around
and said I'm a little
under the weather,
this is after I photographed
him.
Said, he was up all
night with a toothache.
So, he turned around, and I
do have it documented frame
by frame, turned around and
he pulled his tooth out.
And, he spat blood on the floor,
took out a cigarette pack,
put it in there, turned
back to the audience
and said I feel better
and continued.
>> Barry Bergey: Tough guy.
>> Tom Pich: So, everyone, but
I just let it happen, you know.
But, and there is one other
photograph that I'd taken
where there's a light reflection
from one of my flashes
in a mirror to come
clean I left it in there
because that's the
only one that I'm in.
>> Barry Bergey:
Any other questions?
>> I can't imagine how
challenging it must have been,
I can't imagine how challenging
it must have been to decide,
you know, which people and
their photographs were not going
to make the book.
So, you know, was the
process you made a first cut
and then did you swap
out different ones
as you made your decisions?
What was that decision
making process like?
>> Tom Pich: Well, because
our families know each other
so well.
And, I mean, I was involved
my family in my process
and Barry also, what we did is
we came up with our own list.
And, I went to my
family and wrote my list
and Barry did the same.
We took those two lists
and we put them on top.
And, about 75% of
them were the same.
So, we knew those were in.
And then, Barry took it
to the professional step
of thinking geographically and.
>> Barry Bergey: Functionally,
ethnically, different types
of artwork, you know, craft,
music, dance, and so forth.
So, tried to, I think
there are 45
or there's 43 states represented
all together because we tried
to give a broad sense.
The real lesson, I think, from
it is that some folks would say,
you know, this reflects
a diverse America.
And, I think it does.
But, 5that wasn't a
self-conscious decision
in one respect and that is
that excellence reveals
diversity as well.
And, every one of these
artists is excellent.
They are a living treasure.
And so, it isn't hard
to find diversity
when you look for excellence.
Rather than going the other way
around, we look for diversity
and then find the excellence.
The excellence is there.
And, I think it's
revealed in the book.
So, the composite statement is
one, I don't think it's unfair
to say it's a portrait
of America.
It's not the portrait but
it is a portrait of America
and we'd like to hope that.
But, everyone also
had a striking,
you know, image a good story.
And then, we also in the book
put a quote from each artist
so we could give the
artist's voice as well.
So, every image also has a
statement from the artist in it.
Are we ready to wrap up?
>> Elizabeth Peterson:
Thank you so much.
[ Applause ]
I just want to thank Tom
Pich, Berry Bergey for coming.
They're going to be outside
and sign copies of the book
if you want to buy it.
It's a great bargain
it's a great book.
And, thank you all for coming.
Our next Botkan lecture we
hope will be on April 4th
with Barry Ancelet talking
about Cajun culture.
We have to wait until we get a
budget but we're working on it.
And, they're working on it
across the street so hope
to see you back here then.
So, thank you and thank
our speakers once again.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.